Disney which is crumbling their profits
their market share the whole thing and
new CEO Bob Iger who is also old CEO uh
because he was the CEO years ago then
that guy another Bob Bob chapic took in
bobc put the thing put the woke thing on
steroids right Eiger comes in to kind of
clean it up uh here he is talking about
DeSantis and trying to tell people that
Disney's not actually woken they're not
sexualizing kids uh you see if you
believe him what about DeSantis who's
going to be on the husting so to speak
for the next year and he's going he's
made this a part of his campaign
attacking Disney saying it's a woke
Corporation we've put the company on a
pedestal but they really embraced the
idea of getting these sexualized content
in the program line that I'm not willing
to cross I mean that's what he said I
quoted DeSantis there how do you respond
to that well so far what we've said
publicly is that we are
concerned that he has decided to
retaliate against the company for a
position The company took on pending
legislation in that state and frankly
the company was within its right even
though I'm not sure it was handled very
well it was within its right to speak up
on an issue
constitutionally protected right of free
speech and to retaliate against the
company in a way that would be harmful
to the business the notion that Disney
is in any way sexualizing children quite
frankly is is preposterous and
inaccurate the notion that Disney is
sexualizing children is quite frankly
preposterous
Connor are you ready
roll the tape the notion that Disney is
in any way sexualizing children quite
frankly is is preposterous and
inaccurate
to me Pride Celebration spectacular text
to me this morning you know gen Z is 30
to 40 percent queer than the other
Generations mom so Disney better get
with it our leadership over there has
been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda they've been really
open to exploring queer stories I'm on
the production side and so kind of the
only way to have these like canonical
trans characters canonical asexual
characters canonical bisexual characters
is to give them stories where they can
like be their whole selves I identify as
like a biromantic asexual I want to like
add the pop the the pockets of the lgbtq
community That You Don't See I was like
I want to get like day in advance so we
no longer say ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls it's hello everyone or Hello
friends we were targeting gen Z and
Millennials we were targeting a younger
um all this content's going for to kids
who don't know any of this and even if
they're in a household like Keith uh
that have uh supportive parents they're
still getting all of this information
from media of what is normal oh Bob Iger
you're not gonna be a fan of mine
um can any of you in this room tell me
what a canonical asexual character might
be is there a child that's uh say four
or five years old wants Mommy and Daddy
and I could this could happen to me in a
couple years when the kids want to go to
the movie theater what if one of the
boys looks up Daddy I want to see a
canonical asexual character
foreign
I just made that kid a little Asian the
kid became a little Asian there or a
little robotic Daddy I want to see a
canonical asexual baby
how are these people talking about
[Music]